[Music]
good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight so you remember when
Russia invaded Ukraine in February and
at that time our leaders told us this
wasn't some Far Away conflict in Eastern
Europe this was our war
no military should ever be allowed to
invade a Sovereign Nation they told us
Iraq and Afghanistan obviously not
included in that rule the invasion of
Ukraine could not stand because it was a
matter of first principles
but more than that it was a world
historic moral battle that we were
obligated to join it was very clear
Vladimir Putin was pure evil he was
Hitler Reborn the Ukrainian president
zelensky was his Mirror Image he was
saint-like
self-denying Brave honest very handsome
and zelinski was fighting for the very
same ideals that our country was founded
on a number of news outlets including
CNN and the LA Times compared him to
George Washington
so they told us that with one voice
month after month no disagreement
allowed not surprisingly it worked
Americans fell hard for president
zielinski they all did even in rural
areas that voted against Joe Biden you
saw Ukrainian flags hanging from
mailboxes
to many people it felt like World War II
again the good War a battle against
tyranny abroad for the sake of freedom
and democracy at home
well the better part of a year later
it's getting harder and harder to
believe any of this whatever you think
of the war in Ukraine it is pretty clear
that zielinski has no interest in
freedom and democracy in fact zelinski
is far closer to Lenin than to George
Washington
he is a dictator
he is a dangerous authoritarian who has
used a hundred billion in U.S tax
dollars to erect a one-party police
state in Ukraine and that's not an
overstatement over the past year
zielinski has banned opposition parties
he shut down critical media by force
he's arrested his political opponents he
has sent soldiers into churches
zielinski's secret police have raided
monasteries across Ukraine even a
Convent full of nuns and arrested dozens
of priests for no justifiable reason
whatsoever and in clear violation of the
Ukrainian Constitution which no longer
matters
and in the face of this the bite
Administration has said nothing not one
word instead they just continue to push
to send zielinski more tax dollars so
naturally zelenski has become much
Bolder why wouldn't he last week he
announced his plan to ban an entire
religion the Ukrainian Orthodox church
and to seize its property all for being
insufficiently loyal to his regime and
he said it out loud watch this
we have to create such conditions when
any people dependent on the country
aggressor won't be able to manipulate
ukrainians and weaken Ukraine from
within first the National Security and
defense Council instructed the
government to submit to the verhavna
Rada a draft law on making it impossible
for religious organizations affiliated
with centers of influence in the Russian
Federation to operate in Ukraine
a free country does not ban a major
religion just because it's not fully on
board with the political program of the
people running the country
but slendski's doing that and his
cabinet is now devising ways to punish
Christians for practicing their banned
ancient religion in Ukraine quote
personal economic and restrictive
sanctions will be applied to any
Christian caught worshiping in
unapproved ways
now the Ukrainian Orthodox Church is
more than a thousand years old
with the full backing of the Joe Biden
Administration in the U.S Congress
zielinski has decided to ban it
so here's the response of one Bishop to
the news
[Music]
[Music]
you're not allowed to send soldiers into
churches you're not allowed to arrest
dozens of priests because they refuse to
Bow before you you're not allowed to ban
whole religions
so most of the US media most have just
ignored this some have made excuses for
it oh he has to do this because there's
a war
but there's no justification for this
whatsoever
the Ukrainian Orthodox Church is not
Russian it's Ukrainian it has no
connection to the Putin government it is
in fact officially denounced the Russian
invasion of Ukraine so once again there
is no justification for destroying and
banning this church
and yet zelenski's many celebrity
backers in the west have said nothing
about it
and they should know better
in May George W bush the great defender
of Christendom met with zelenski on a
zoom call and afterward described him as
the Winston Churchill of our time a man
who should be praised for his quote
commitment to Liberty
so where's George W bush on this
question now that his friend the George
Washington of Ukraine has banned a form
of Christianity in that country well
Georgie bush has been silent as well so
have many purportedly Christian members
of Congress they're backing his lenski
no matter how many Christians he arrests
no matter how many churches he seizes
to the Ukrainian people
you can expect the Congress to
to be there with you in terms of
supporting your efforts to maintain your
freedom everything that we can do to be
helpful to them as they fight for as
they fight for their freedom I think the
history of the 21st century turns on how
fiercely we defend freedom in Ukraine we
will continue to provide military
equipment so that Ukraine can defend its
territory and its freedom the United
States will continue our unwavering
support for Ukraine as it defends its
freedom and let's get the job done so
that we can save lives in Ukraine and
defend the cause of Freedom the Free
World had no choice
America could not stand by the American
people did what they always have done
defend Freedom around the world
every single person you just watched has
campaigned many to make a habit of
campaigning Lindsey Graham ladies and
gentlemen in Christian churches in the
United States well a single Christian
leader say anything to them about this
you are funding the destruction of
Christianity in Ukraine
oh but it's the cause of Freedom really
the reality is that ukrainians cannot
listen to Media Outlets that criticize
the zelenski government because they've
been banned they cannot play music from
Russian singers no this is not in
taliban-controlled Afghanistan this is
in the Democracy of Ukraine that we
support they can't play music from
Russian singers they can't vote for an
opposition party because they've all
been shut down and now their churches
are being raided and they're priests
arrested
so the fact that our leaders are calling
this Freedom tells you a lot about what
they're planning here of course why
would you defend this because you
approve of it
for its part Ukraine's defense Ministry
has stopped pretending this is about
Freedom they're just happy they're
getting paid and they're finally
crushing any opposition in their own
country
and that's why Ukraine's military is now
using your tax dollars to produce
choreographed dance videos for social
media consumption sort of like the covid
nurses here's one of them
yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it's just a grotesque post-modern psyop
and anyone who's fallen for this is
brain damaged this is the same Ukrainian
defense Ministry that lied about the
ghost of Kiev and the sailors who cursed
out the Russian ship now they're just
having fun
because they're beating their real
enemies which of course as always are
domestic and Time Magazine is fully on
board with this they just informed their
four remaining readers that zelenski's
president is the person of the year
and the media chorus is in full screen
John Meacham the purported historian in
MSNBC believes that zielinski is really
a lot like the Pope
zielinski is being fired by the best
fundamental impulses in human nature
which is to stand to defend to
articulate to fight back
and I think it's also important to
remember that he is a performer uh
that's where he started John Paul II was
a performer Ronald Reagan was a
performer Winston Churchill understood
the means of the media of his time he
understood the power of radio Franklin
Roosevelt understood radio that's it's
not coincidental that great leaders
understand
great leaders so if they'll defend a man
who shut down opposition media arrested
his political opponents arrested priests
sent the Army into monasteries and then
banned a religion if they'll defend all
of that and call it Liberty
they'll defend anything
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight